[Music]
foreign
you're an interesting man
Scotland
um I don't know who you are but
you've made a big mistake
okay
I'm an Avenger
I've called the other Avengers you're an
Avenger
have I killed you before
what
they all blow together after a while
you're not the one with the hammer
that's Thor
we get confused a lot similar body types
who are you
just a man
we've lost a lot of time
like you
but we can help each other with that
a lot has changed about my life
we literally saved the world
but right now the only job I want is
being a dad
Scotland
if you want to get out of here
and I need to get out of here bring me
what I want what's that
you cannot trust him
okay who this guy is I just lost so much
time
after he thinks he's a god
everything you call a life
I will burn out of time he's got Cassie
we'll stop him together
you think you can beat me
ready pd13 in theaters February 17 get
tickets now
[Music]
is